it is great to be joined today by maxim
tarik who is the CEO of the ask protocol
at that is spelled asq and also CEO of
ask.fm both projects which we'll be
talking about today Maxim it's so great
to have you on you know you're dealing
with an issue that we talk about a lot
on our program which is media
consolidation the fact that media and
digital media news media social media
we're talking about very few companies
that have an extraordinary amount of
control over the total usage of these
platforms can you first talk about that
a little quantify how bad the
consolidation is yeah first of all
thanks for having me on the show sure
it's a big pleasure interesting
conversation hopefully so yeah we see
the problem we operate our own social
network called ask.fm and we see the
problem and were easily we noticed the
situation where the content basically
belongs to you several social media
platforms and this content can be easily
manipulated or for the whole audience
all those social media platforms I see
that this is a big issue that's how
basically Donald Trump became a
President of the United States
that's how brexit happened in the UK
which is not cool as well I'm not big
fan of both of those historic moments
and I'm blame on that those social media
platforms that basically gave people in
easy access to manipulation of tools and
yeah I think it's it's not that right
and when you talk about the way that
that that the manipulation happens are
you talking about algorithms and the
sort of echo chambers that they create
or are you talking about more than just
that just so that we really fully
understand it the project yeah I'm
talking about both stock right so those
platforms that obviously that we are
talking about three
or media platforms basically they they
can easily control the media and control
the content that's been created on the
platform by algorithms by I by those
tools and mechanism that for example
right now I basically can hardly control
my newsfeed on Facebook and I can count
hardly control what kind of content I
will see on YouTube
sometimes I'm see I can see different
political topics that I don't want to
see why why do I see it but third
parties that are involved on those
social media platforms they can easily
do it by promoting this content and and
by other tools so I think you know our
audience has a pretty good grasp of the
problem that we're dealing with here and
they deal with it even on platforms
where they might watch my program like
YouTube and Twitter and Facebook so what
does ask proposed to do to deal with
this problem we are going to tackle two
problem actually first is a Content
manipulation to make sure that those
people who create the content on our
platform on and other social media
platforms they are real people not fake
profiles no BOTS they are on a platform
they will have rating based on
blockchain
blockchain will help will help us to
track what and where this content coming
from from what kind of user so with with
the blockchain it will be easy traceable
and then the second problem that we are
going to tackle and maybe it's even
bigger it's the fair reward for the
content creators obviously you are the
content creator you are in a good
example it's nice talking to you about
that we want to make sure that every
person who will participate with ask
protocol platform will get a fair reward
from the consumers of their content so
for example imagine the news website
local news website person can easily you
if asked protocol we will be implemented
on this news website person can easily
promote the content that you can create
on this
site through the whole network of ask
protocol which will give him two things
first of all he will get additional
audience because it will be spreaded
within all ask protocol and second of
all he can choose what kind of revenue
model he want to get and what kind of
revenue stream you want to get as a
reward for the content he creates so he
can choose paywall when the part of
video or or text will be visible the
second part will be closed and person
should pay for it
or it will be tips or it will be some
we're gonna have around seven reward
models that's basically how it can work
so we have a real use case on a
scrambler the girl she's a big
influencer for our community on askin
she has thousands of followers on our
platform and she is basically beauty
bloggers from Thailand she's a young
girl she creates the fantastic content
about beauty stuff for audience in
Thailand she has hundreds of thousand
views for every video but she has zero
dollars in revenue because she's too
small for the for the current social
media platform to get a reward from them
so we want to tackle this problem we
want to create the fair ecosystem and
fur technology were such content
creators like small content creators
influencers will get a fair reward from
the community called from the followers
that they currently have so that's what
our solution about initially we were
thinking about doing the organization of
our platform called ask.fm to motivate
people to create high quality answers on
professional and non-professional and
social topics but right now we decided
to build the technology that can be
implemented into other social media
platforms without any limitation to
so a little bit there's there's a lot
there and there's a you know a lot of
different questions that that we
directions we could go in in the limited
time that we have how does your
organization make money by facilitating
this is it from transaction fees or or
how will that work yeah so with ask
protocol we are not gonna charge
anything so the revenue model is just
talking appreciation for us so we expect
that we will build the technology that
will be used and the agility talking
that can be a fuel for our technology
will be actually used inside the
platform so in the current blockchain
society it's not it's not a really big
topic right now because in most cases
tokens are used to trade on exchanges
finance tokens use in 14% of the usage
is just inside of the platform of
finance the rest of them are just tokens
that being traded on exchange this is
not the way how we want to go so you
want to build technology with the token
that will be used inside of ask ask fm
and other potential social media
platforms that will be implemented ask
protocol so that's that's how we see
will work in the future when it comes to
the data storage element can you talk a
little bit about how there's also the
possibility of being rewarded with the
tokens for storing data and what control
people have over that yeah so the as we
are going to build a fully decentralized
solution we are going to build the
technology with distributed storage and
those people who want to participate in
our in our economy who want to make
money as a reward for the content
storage they can basically do it by
storing the content and given an access
to our community that's that's how it
will work
is there protection in the system that
you're developing from the possibility
of a content creator being demonetised
so like a year and a half ago there was
this big D monetization crisis on
YouTube which affected us and many other
content creators because there was sort
of like a centralized power which said
we are not going to monetize certain
types of content and the publisher
doesn't really have any control over
that is that something that can happen
with your protocol or is there
protection against that that's the
beauty of our protocol is it it will be
fully decentralized we are going to
build a solution that will be used by
our community and only community will
decide what amount of money will it cost
and what what amount of money they want
to donate or pay for the content so
there will be no central power that will
decide how much this or this content
will cost so it's up to market to decide
how much they want to pay for the
content and so in other words if there's
content that on a platform that
centralized might be ineligible for
monetization either because of its
sensitive nature or whatever else with
your protocol if there is a demand for
that content and presumably if the
content is not illegal in nature it
would remain eligible for monetization
period correct absolutely correct of
course we will make sure that the
content that will be stored on our
protocol is fully legal fully compliant
because we need to make sure that for
our community we will deliver only high
quality content with no risks and we
need to be understand that we need to
have a safe environment for our
community there's no bullying and other
issues that potentially all social media
platform can have maximum can you talk
briefly about the sort of timeline for
the launch of the token ico fundraising
to give our audience
so we are right now we are on a private
private stage so we are doing
fundraising from funds all over the
world in Asia we are going to do it till
the end of the year after that we are
thinking about doing the crowd sale for
our community because it's we feel that
we should give our community an
opportunity to participate in our future
future economy so we are going to
thinking about launch in the public sale
early next year in terms of technology
we already started building that we have
a high quality technical team that
together with our partners trying to
tackle those issues to build a real
solution on the blockchain that will be
usable on other social media platforms
we are going to launch 100% ready
protocol in the q3 next year and the
first stage of MVP will be ready in q1
next year we have been speaking with
maxim tarik who is the CEO of ask
protocol that's asq protocol and CEO of
sq FM you can learn much more about the
project by using the links in the video
description Maxim thank you so much for
talking to us today thank you David and
thanks for having me and have a good day